I started a dental online education
platform which became very popular when
I started it I had no idea that how can
I reach my target audience the problem
was that how can I help people who are
in need of a solution to their problem
that's when I thought about learning
about digital marketing I completed
digital marketing specialization from
Simply learn now this course taught me
the basics and advanced of search engine
optimization and that helped me increase
traffic to my website and as a result my
conversions grew and my Revenue
increased more than 30 percent
hi I'm Rahul Monga I am the founder of
itd online where I help people prepare
for their Dental entrance exams in
Canada United States Australia and New
Zealand I migrated to Canada in 2011 and
I completed my dental equivalency from
National dental Examining Board of
Canada I launched my platform in 2018
but it was not until 2020 when I sold my
first online course I felt that if I
become proficient in digital marketing I
could flourish and I can expand my
online business I thought about learning
from the best which I came across when I
saw and heard about simply learn and
that's when I chose to enroll myself in
digital marketing specialization program
the program from Simply learn
did not talk me just digital marketing
it helped me to learn about effective
communication using those principles I
was able to apply those techniques into
my platform and I gained huge amount of
results My overall experience with
has been great the lectures are bite
size which means
you will never feel overwhelmed when I
am free I usually like to work work out
I like biking and would like to spend
time with my family by learning new
things we can always unlock our
potential and in that way it will
contribute not to our success but to the
people around us who are being inspired
by us